[Music]
we started welcome to session number 35
in the worlds of speculative fiction
series each thinker that we look at this
time we're doing Lewis Carroll or
Charles dots and focusing mostly on the
Alice stuff although I did bring his I'm
not gonna bore you with symbolic logic
in the game of logic we're not going to
do any exercises but he is it's kind of
an interesting guy in that sense what we
do in this is we talk a little bit about
biography and an awful lot about world
building when there is a world that's
being built and then philosophical
themes we usually have a lot of
discussion going on during during these
sessions we often go to the point where
the library is about ready to kick us
out but we'll see how far we go with
Alice in Wonderland so welcome to
everybody who's here I'm glad to see
some new faces I've got two things for
you one and then I apologize for the
small print you can tell I printed it
out at work and things came out a little
bit smaller than I'd intended so if
you're like me you know it's a little
hard to read but there's a time line
that we usually have with things that
happen to the person and that they're
books on the other side and then I've
got a bunch of passages that I thought
would be interesting to reference so
Lewis Carroll you know there's a pen
name the real guy his name as as Charles
Dodgson and I noticed that mr. actually
misspelled his name and they added an
extra e but he probably wouldn't care
about that all that much or he'd make a
joke about it somebody whose was
entirely in the the 19th century you
notice that he dies shortly before the
turn of the century it'd be interesting
if he live longer and got to actually
see what people were making of the new
century and if he was around today and
saw all of the things
been done with his his works and how
much influence he's exercised on so many
different writers and thinkers I think
he would be probably gratified but also
surprised it'd be interesting to see
what he'd make up like Disney turning
Alison Wonderland into a cartoon
wouldn't it so what do you want to shoot
it should be should we switch it up here
at all and talk about the world or
should we go through the biography as we
usually do first what are your feelings
since we bought all the new crowd oh
yeah and I you know I wrote the Alice
books when I was a kid when I was in
undergraduate I was a math and
philosophy major so I found his
Balaklava book at Half Price Books here
in in Brookfield and worked my way
through it and it was it was done in a
very different style than the other
logic stuff that I was studying cause he
had his own notation but it was a lot of
fun it was quite quite cool
he turned logic into something like a
game that you could play with counters
and I think he was quite a good teacher
apparently he didn't really like
teaching much but he but he did it as
sort of a chore so let's see let's jump
in so his his mother and father lived in
this area it's kind of a country place
in England arse brewery and he's born
there he's the third child of a whole
brood that's going to be born and then
eventually they they relocate to Croft
on tazed which is sort of a residence
his father's a parson so it is living
and I guess you'd say a rectory they're
part of the Church of England and for
for most of his childhood he's actually
homeschooled
apparently was very brilliant devoured
books
have you know they let him read what he
wanted to read and then there was an
awful lot of great attention paid to
things because he could he could manage
things and then he goes to rugby and
rugby was one of the oldest now I always
get private-public mixed up with with
the prince public schools private
schools yeah so I think it's one of the
oldest public schools and apparently the
bullying was a really big problem there
and he wasn't bullied so much but but he
got in a lot of fights
defending the younger kids who are being
bullied they said that he hadn't used
his fists quite often and so he wasn't
really happy about that leaves rugby and
then he is he's ready to go to
university so he enrolls at the
University of Oxford in christchurch
college and takes about there's some
mix-up so it takes a while before he can
actually get rooms there so he's entered
in college but he's not actually there
at the college until there's some some
rooms available and he gets there and
almost immediately after that he gets
word got to go back home his mother is
dying
and she dies of inflammation of the
brain before he can get there he goes
back to college doesn't take him long he
doesn't go for a fall for years he
graduates with his bachelor's he was
studying both mathematics and class
classics mathematics was Reaper
ticularly excelled and then shortly
after that he's he's awarded a
lectureship which means that now he's
got teaching obligations and he spent a
good portion of career teaching
undergraduates you know the basic
classes and mathematics he doesn't
appear to have enjoyed it an awful lot
but you know I can understand that I get
to teach things that I find you know
very exciting and and I often manage to
get my students to find it halfway
exciting in philosophy right if at least
half the class is excited
half the time that's probably pretty
good I think math is a bit of a harder
sell all of you can confirm this y'all
had math classes some of you may have
may have done some some things with that
he starts using the the name Lewis
Carroll fairly early on and the same
community he does that and starts you
know writing little little bits and
pieces of things he also gets his first
camera and Carroll this is this is a
sort of controversial thing that we'll
get into in just a moment but Carroll
was a big photographer and he it was
actually a great way to meet famous
people because you could offer to take
their photograph which is kind of a big
production that's time and then you know
they was they would hang out with you so
he used that to get to meet a lot of
people he also took a lot of photographs
of children and you know there have been
rumors that that he was attracted to
children in part because some of them
the children are nude usually as far as
we can tell the parents were their
presence during it gave permission and
then there's been a lot of back and
forth really since the 90s when I was
looking into this about where where did
his attractions lie it's clear that he
had lady friends so it wasn't if he was
interested in children he certainly also
had a you know not necessarily sexual
relations but partly romantic relations
on the side he carried on great deal of
correspondence and you know arranged to
have dinners and things like that which
exactly what that meant
yes they have I don't know where the
archive is but his letters not only have
been saved and archived he created a
classification system for his letters he
was he was really insistent that he said
you bring this book perfect America so
he writes this thing eight or nine wise
words about letter writing sort of close
to the end of his life but in it one of
the chapters is specifically on how you
want to forget exactly the title but
it's like you you're doing yourself a
disservice if you don't classify and
track all your letters because what if
one of your friends says well you know
letter three weeks ago you said blah
blah blah and you think that you didn't
say that well you know exactly where
that letter is so he he thought that
what you should do and he followed this
himself is for each letter than you
write you have to put it in an entry
into this log who the letter went to
when it went what the subject matter of
the letter is I mean nowadays people I
guess would put that into a spreadsheet
you know and he was photocopy
assuredness you know but he didn't say
[Music]
yeah well I don't know if he did or
didn't I don't know that much about it
because I wasn't that that interests
that other than noting the fact that he
seemed to be very particular about the
wouldn't want to do this he's suggesting
that his advice to all of us by the way
he's not just saying that that he should
do that
all of us when we write letters we
should keep track of them now how many
of us write letters that sounds like a
major well I don't know I might as a
teacher I can't picture too many my
peers doing that I know it sounds like
something you would ask your student to
do it to keep track of all your home oh
yeah yeah you know totally off topic
my uncle Hubert he was a great uncle
actually he only had a sixth grade
education but he was one of the best
educated men that I knew because he read
all the time in his spare time and he
was very interested in learning things
about science and about geography and he
actually tracked all we have these
notebooks at home
he tracked all the books that he read
and he would he would write a little
note about it sometime he was a little
prudish like too much sex in this book
good plot characters are weak you know I
don't know if he ever reread books but
he he tracked all these things and then
he also did that with movies too he
would I guess go to a movie or see one
on TV and he'd you know write down what
he thought about it and he put it into
just like a little spiral notebook and
yeah yeah I mean I I like reading here
yeah and it's not like they're they're
very long entries but it's more than I
think most of us do well and I think
sometimes for some people maybe many
people yeah I kept writing or
highlighting text sort of risa men sit
in your memory
yeah you know so just you know even if
you never go back and look at it again
somehow it's it's there because it's
something you made mention it and you
saw it visually some of it yeah I
actually have tons of these legal pads
unorganized
they're not organized at all and and I
have the bad habit of like taking notes
on a bunch of different things a bunch
of different subjects in the Eagle pads
like I go to a conference or something I
bring a legal pad with me and I'm
listening to the person speaking and I'm
writing down what they're talking about
and then I have a different idea to the
next page and write about that and I
really go back to them to see what's in
them there's there's probably a lot of
interesting stuff I had the times that I
do go back some of the time I open it up
I'm like what the hell is this
[Music]
experience unfortunately now maybe maybe
it was Carroll did but yeah so so anyway
we have is his writings and he that year
he also meets uh Alice Liddell who may
in fact be the analyst a lot of people
think she was the
I talked about in Alice in Wonderland
certainly he was very close to the
Liddell's he winds up receiving an MA
that's the highest that he goes it was
quite common back then to that would be
a terminal degree master's degree you
know the German university is that's
reading like you need to do a PhD and
then we caught on with that here in the
states because we imitated the German
universities but but there was quite
often you'd finish with a master's and
that gave him the right to do many more
things at Oxford now another thing that
was going on is he was supposed to be
getting ordained and ordination in the
Church of England didn't mean that had
to be celibate for life the way what if
he was a Roman Catholic but it didn't
mean that he was supposed to be celibate
until he got married and he didn't want
to get ordained as a matter of fact he'd
try to do everything he could to get out
of it and he does get her a date as a
deacon he was supposed to be ordained
first as a deacon and then as a priest
and he got the bishop to make an
exception for him and it's a real big
exception because according to the rules
of Christ's Church if he didn't get
ordained as a priest he was supposed to
be expelled so who knows what he did but
he got the he got the right people to
decide that he didn't have to do that
and then he in in 1862 he's spending a
good bit of time with the Liddell family
and he goes on a rowing trip that played
a big role in the development of this
stuff he goes on a rowing tripping
picnic with them and he first starts
telling the Alice story and he starts
telling it orally at first rather than
writing it down he's a good storyteller
and then eventually he writes it down
and the first manuscript I think of it
as it's not called Alice in Wonderland
it's called Alice something about down
below
and it's not quite the full book of
Alice in Wonderland but he presents her
with a copy of it and then eventually
finds a illustrator he thinks that it's
really important of good illustrations
finds an illustrator produces Alice in
Wonderland and then his literary career
really takes off that becomes big hip
quite famous a little bit later on he in
Sylvia and Bruno which is writing okay
so that is in 1889 so you know good more
than 20 years after that he says I don't
know if Alice in Wonderland was an
original story it was at least no
conscious imitator and writing it but I
do know that sense it came out something
like a dozen storybooks have appeared on
identically the same pattern the path
that timidly explored believing myself
through the first that ever burst into
that silence see is now meeting the high
road all the wayside flowers have long
ago been trampled into dust and it would
be courting disaster for me to attempt
that style again so he's saying you know
too many other people have imitated me
I'm not going to do Alice in Wonderland
again I'm gonna do a different kind of
book which is equally nonsensical but it
doesn't have the same character he does
write a follow-up to Alice in Wonderland
which is through the looking-glass which
is a bit longer book and I think it's
myself and here's something I'd like
your opinions on not that I don't want
your opinions on other things but I
consider when I'm reading them i I like
through the looking-glass a lot more
than I do
Allisyn wonder that else water that
seems kind of can I aimless to me it
doesn't doesn't cover quite as much what
did it what's the reactions that you've
had to reading both of them
there's an old small and goes a story's
not just one thing
happening after another and I would
agree with you ounces adventure
something happening like an a drink
where are you yeah beautiful things to
another until you wake from the dream
where as through the looking-glass feels
more like well those Carol doing this or
Bill Nighy in the eighteen hundred's
lesson on and I think it's strong yeah
there is a narrative coherence with the
chessboard squares to write lines you
know like the White Plains saying after
one as fast as you can to stay in one
place yeah feels like Carol trying to
get out certain kinds of ideas in that
matter okay
one of the rest do you think comparing
the two of them equally good one better
than the other yeah yeah I think I think
I'm looking glass has more of a plot but
I don't know if I like it better okay
wonder lands a lot of fun yeah I know
it's a bad children's book yeah there's
more weird things that kids can get into
it yeah I thought the jokes were bigger
in the first one yeah you know the one
that didn't the second one that I found
the funniest was actually the terrible
trick that the walrus did on the poor
oysters yeah well let's talk a little
bit more about whatever else he's doing
so he now he becomes quite famous with
with Alice in Wonderland there is a
story that that Queen Victoria demanded
that like he dedicated the next book to
her and he dedicated something some you
know mathematics but he said that that's
complete fabrication so probably and we
could imagine that that
it's actually not the case he does a
little bit of traveling he goes through
Europe through France Belgium and then
Germany into Russia with this this
person who is an ordained minister Henry
and Perry Lydon in 1876 his father dies
and so now you know I suppose he's sort
of the head of the family I think he's
the first boy in the family so he has a
good bit of money and he acquires the
lease this place the chestnuts and his
siblings moved there and that that's
where they live he still stays in Oxford
living living in his rooms and he starts
publishing other things as well and I
only have the books in here he's
publishing a whole bunch of other stuff
shorter works here and there that he
thought he was turning out he travels to
Scotland and then he starts summering in
Eastbourne by 1880 he suddenly gives up
photography and that's the year when he
also starts to have some some serious
health problems he it's not clear
whether he had migraines before that or
whether this is his first migraine but
he starts experiencing migraine with
aura which is kind of a disconcerting
thing those of those who suffered from
it I've heard descriptions of it it
sounds pretty awful
eventually he gives up lecturing but he
keeps his rooms at Christchurch and he
wants to devote more time to writing and
publishing and the publications you
notice what he what he's doing
throughout this some of them are you
know stories some of them are
mathematics books some of them are just
nonsense things like the hunting of the
snark and phantasmagoria and other poems
and he continues doing that he's also
inventing things I only put two of his
inventions in there one is this stamp
case again he's a big proponent of
letters and he thinks that everybody
should have their own stamp case he was
actually quite good at branding he talks
about it in his book about
the eight or nine wise words about
letter writing and the AI also invents
this thing nicht ography which is the
art of writing notes to yourself in the
middle of the night in bed
so like you wake up from a dream or are
you wake up in the middle of the night
and have a thought how do you get that
down without turning the lights on so he
thought about Braille and he comes up
with a system that that's kind of like
that he also comes up with the Nick to
graph a thing that you can use to do the
writing interestingly it not only is the
26 letters
he also took really common words like
love and that's got its own little
cipher so he's you know very clever when
it comes to this sort of stuff um he
writes you know one other you could call
it narrative work that's not just
nonsense stuff Sylvia and Bruno the
follow up a bit later on I guess you
know what the tortoise said to Achilles
that that's also I mean it's a
mathematical work but it's also a
narrative work in some respects and he
dies of pneumonia he gets sick in 1898
dies and is buried the area's family
home in in Guilford bachelors entire
life but had quite a few women
correspondence some of whom he enticed
to come down to Oxford and dinner with
him which I guess was kind of a big
production some of them were
considerably younger than him you know
there's there's one case I remember
reading about where he was I think 54
she was 20-something and he's writing
back and forth to her and convincing her
to
down there and that's you know he's a
family man he is somebody who was a
uncle both to his nieces and nephews but
also he was sort of the uncle that we
talk about where they're a family friend
you know and seems you know to be quite
charming I don't know much about his
teaching I read it about anybody who
took classes with him but we could
imagine he he probably was fairly
competent at that I don't think at that
time you had to be a particular if he
could teach her once you had a position
so that that's his biography there's
there's there's you know it's enough
that we can put it out one page as
opposed to some of the thinkers who we
have to get two pages for let's talk
about world-building
so can we actually is there enough in
Alice in Wonderland and through the
looking-glass to talk about creating a
narrative world or is it like with some
of the the people we've looked at where
we're really just getting a tiny little
selection of something that could be a
much larger he's not a Tolkien he's not
a a george RR martin you know he's not
creating a gigantic universe that has
its own well spelled out languages or
lineages or anything like that it's kind
of put together almost on the fly isn't
it well I was gonna say yeah I guess for
me like world building is there whether
or not it feels like a world you can say
things about is can you answer the
question like was something happening
before I was more honored over the same
thing by something nothing interesting
okay
and it seems like generally
like it's it's happening for her benefit
when she's there and you don't get a
feeling that there was something going
on before or I have to work like that
see I I have the opposite feeling I kind
of feel like it's a there is a world
that she intrudes into okay and there's
stuff happening but it's stuff that
doesn't make a hell of a lot of sense
and and it's almost like they they all
take it for granted that this crazy
stuff let's so they go through bout
Tweedledee and Tweedledum right
they were they were they've already got
this pattern of like fighting every so
often they know to go get their stuff I
suppose on that level like late with an
antique or use oh right yeah yeah you
see these happening but you get the
impression that they're cyclical like
that the Mad Tea Party is always been
going on yeah it seems like a world
where nothing changes except when Alice
comes into the upset thing because when
you assume that those are just patterns
would you I've been going on until
analysts I can see yeah so it is I mean
he's he's clearly gesturing out of there
for us
is there enough there for us to feel
like we we understand how that world
works or are we just like seeing just
the tiniest bit of it and maybe there's
like vast stuff beyond and or just a
void that you know doesn't make any
sense does he give us or here's another
way to think about it does he give us
enough pieces so that we can figure out
if we wanted to extend the world what
the pattern would look like why
partially because exert nonsensical and
inconsistent and it's sort of built on
wordplay more than yeah not okay where
you know you have this holiday where you
turn everything upside down on the
conference or the Kings and the whole
point of having that is to show why you
have things the way they are the rest of
the year
and it seems like Carol is having things
be upside down in this world to point
out how things work in ours too you know
as you went to a child by having people
speak nonsense you can explain logic to
them well I don't know that he's I don't
know that he's succeeding and conveying
like what a logical thing would be it is
definitely this is one of the themes I
want to talk about he is showing that
language can be twisted in all different
directions you know yeah well uh the
wordplay between people you know where
Alice constantly finds herself at a
disadvantage it's only it's pretty rare
that she actually like manages to come
out on top in the back and forth arguing
with anybody
no she doesn't usually given last one
yeah she doesn't get to define what the
situation is they they've already like
figured though they that she says
something and then they take it in a way
she didn't intend and then she's like
well what do I do now you know you know
I think of it as a dream and his
attempts to put a little girls
frustrations living in his golf world in
a dream okay and and in the dream her
frustrations are expressed through these
various experiences she has and
basically I think that's what it's about
this idea of how she sees the world and
how it would be perceived in a dream
have you seen as when you're seeing
young vampires film about us I don't
think so
as a director and did an adaptation
using a lot of stop motion of
Alice in Wonderland and all of the
things that Alice encounters in his
adaptation I think she sees like in the
world that she's in before she falls
asleep so they exactly yeah and then
trying to try to get her way as a child
and thing it's frustrating adults of
various types interfere with her plans
and confuse her and tell her put her in
her place and it's all there
yeah so she never has the key or the
cipher to figure things out and adults I
already have a system set up that she
has to adapt yourself to but it just
seems irrational and it's like a dream
it jumps around
you're never in one place everybody long
things are being in small yeah but it's
irrational the way a dream is and I
think that was his plan that's all it
also to be clever and write poetry and
get that in there and do some good pun
insulin yeah like any thoughts
parents of ever to were some kind of a
social criticism of the monarchy during
the time in England and she was third in
her role because the Queen's are so
naughty here well that everything and
there was some nation's prevalence of
power and and then she was like an
observer to come in when she came in she
was like a disrupter
of all of this yeah that just took place
and she came in observing you but she
also disrupted it and I don't know I you
know I read this so long ago so I
haven't I don't have anything real and I
should have reread it but it just at the
time that's fine as you feel like
Carol's trying to illustrate the world
is a violent place through that as well
I was rereading Alice in Wonderland I
was kinda shocked by how much violence
is being done to around
do you think that's going well look at
the world well no I mean I came here I
didn't think it was a lot more fun
no no I mean that would have been during
the Victorian era but I mean it just I
just see her as somehow disrupting the
social order that's taking place in and
then again there the rigidity and
whatever of the Victorian era to just
coming in and saying you know I just
thought this may be because in the 60s
and 70s and we're in school movies
everything was social criticism because
that was the time and I think of the
rigidity in his mind or in his
professional background I mean the
algebraic geometry the say Frank I mean
that's a whole different very structured
yeah attentive world so maybe some of
this is a criticism about the world that
he otherwise may be living in and the
academic world of Oxford was very like
tradition-bound you know I mean we you
know like with the having to become
ordained you know we think about that
you have to like so you're gonna stay at
the weirdest technology you know working
at marquette for example imagine if they
like me so I'm gonna teach some classes
for that man if they made me like you
know recite the Liturgy of the hours
each day or something like that you know
but it was it was very religious based
and it was also just classics it wasn't
any science and spirit got mathematics
in there but it was I mean until the
German influence came in there wasn't
even any real education it was just more
you know classical stuff and that's
written yet
you're on the British of the whole
traditionally just Cambridge spending me
yeah they were not during that time he
was he was one of them about three or
four people who are making contributions
to the development of logic John Stuart
Mill would be earlier than him but then
you know
another English guy right who else there
were quite a few they were kind of
figuring out the same sort of stuff that
he was he was figuring out an advancing
formal logic getting away from her
Aristotelian logic which is it's not
very useful for a lot of things turns
out and in a Carol is kind of like he's
not actually like leading he's sort of
like in the middle pack when it comes to
to those developments but to go back to
the violent thing yeah there's there's a
lot of violence in this as a matter of
fact I was thinking about how you know
when she first starts talking to that
the tea party right she starts
mentioning her cat and the mouse doesn't
like that and then she like she's like
well let me try a different tact let me
talk about my dog and man is he good at
like ripping up rats oh screwed it up
again and it doesn't she just you know
sort of takes it for granted that the
world is like that you know things eat
each other and people do things to each
other
she never like actually says well nobody
should like exercise arbitrary power be
to each other she just says don't do it
in this case you know she was that like
you know pull calling the entire Queen
getting to execute people thing into
question she's just saying this why are
you executing this person and then it
turns out that the Queen never actually
gets to cut off anybody's head the King
just humors her lets her rant about that
you know but but nobody who does get
their heads cut off but he was writing
to the general population right and then
what ideal and they really nice
especially though - right well I'm just
it's a picture book so I think pardon
yeah the ideas what was that part of the
camouflage that he is really just taking
the monarchy which the commoner knows
not much about but if they feel the
consequences oh so this is irrational it
seems to me the red queen isn't anything
like the British monarchy at that point
well I didn't yell that it's it's very
violent that you know he couldn't he can
be violent because it's all fantasy
anyway right well it isn't or it isn't a
reality that you know a picket or
whatever it is it's the there's the idea
you know I mean it's not that it's the
power structure more than the actual
person of emulating another person but
does he pitch it I mean to be safe yeah
and to continue is if it is criticism he
pitches it more for children but don't
some critics or other thinkers think hey
this is a way of exposing the workings
of the monarchy or the effects on the
population I just answers can go very
deep into any of those sorts of things
and there's other there's other novels
or works doing that that cannot work at
the time and it's a tendency as people
endlessly done with Tolkien to try and
find one-to-one meetings where they're
necessary yeah I mean it was it was
popular for a long time to do like
psychoanalytic readings of Alice and
that's part of where some of the you
know rumors about him and being a
pedophile get that started with you know
because they read all this
psychoanalytic stuff in
oh she's falling into a well that
signifies his desire for her and I mean
it seems kind of silly now well as silly
as the books right but but people took
that very seriously like in the 30s and
40s and 50s so I don't know there's
quite a few different readings there's
there's actually a book Alice in
Wonderland in philosophy that is a whole
set of essays and they all have
different interpretations on what's
going out of the book you know and and
quite a few of them quite frankly I read
my way through it quite a few of them
are pretty implausible Neil Gaiman a lot
of fans know this isn't even a little
Stardust based on context
like it's fairytales and everything like
that and got a lot of people all been
anointed and because they kept trying to
find like what I was bound oh he said
one way the interviewer was asking like
what's the deeper meaning that's what
are you trying to say so Tracy it's like
my screen it's supposed to make your
happy when you finish those and the guy
who really didn't like that you have to
have it being about something it makes
me want a little bit of like what was
Carol wasn't just writing a story that
he enjoyed writing that he'd been sort
of telling and building up and maybe
themes crept in there because I don't
think you can write without them yeah I
mean inevitably you're going to bring in
some some ideas from your work or your
your environment or some of those those
types of wake up factors right give it
giving you some content as you know as
the story coming first and then it turns
into an allegory yeah yeah for animals
but this if there are deeper meanings in
it I think as well for Wonderland it
said it's about logic problems and you
know the use of language and stuff and
yeah you know he was you think
mathematics is rigid but mathematicians
think it's a lot of fun oh yeah I
wouldn't have been oh I don't think
mathematics with your edge if you create
mathematics is I mean it's like music
yes one of the okay this is unstructured
far more subverting structure it's not
out of structure but it's it's kind of
skewed right so one of the themes I
wanted to bring up was the connection
between language and that logic because
he has a logician and and I we talked
about this a little bit already these
characters keep on subverting what alice
is doing so she'll she'll try to make
sense of the world and I may they said
no no you've got it wrong here's how
things really
and I picked out a couple passages that
fit that quite quite well one of them
has to do with brings in nonsense and
it's it's the one that's the third one
down on the first page it's time for you
to answer now the Queen said looking at
a watch open your mouth a little bit
wider when you speak and I always say
your majesty and Alice says I only
wanted to see what the garden was like
your majesty
that's right said the Queen panning
around the head which Alice didn't like
at all though when you say garden I've
seen gardens compared with which this
would be a wilderness Alice didn't dare
to argue the point but went on and I
thought I'd try to find my way to the
top of that hill when you say hail the
Queen interrupted I could show you hills
in comparison with what you'd call that
a valley no I shouldn't say I was
surprised into contradicting her at last
Hill can't be a value no that would be
nonsense
there's the great line the Red Queen
shook her head you may call it nonsense
if you like but I have heard nonsense
compared with which that would be as
sensible as a dictionary
Alice curtsey it again as she was
refrained from the Queen stone that she
was a little offended and walked on in
silence until they got to the top of the
little hill so we've got this
one-upsmanship happening right and I
think a lot of the characters are doing
that to Alice there you know she thinks
she's finally got her Harry handle on
things and then they switch it up and
they do it by you know changing the the
language that's being used because
nothing so language is larger than logic
right so logic has to articulate itself
through language but languages is so
malleable and in this case so that it
starts out not too bad right it's just a
typical I've got a better you know
experience than you do you know I've
seen gardens that go they make your
garden look like nothing and then the
Queen says you know I've seen hills that
would would make your Hill look like a
valley so there's a already there's a
dictionnaire and Hill can't be a valley
and Alice knows that and then she points
out that it's nonsense and at that point
if it was a logical world they should
stop you know oh we hit the absurdity
we had nonsense but Carol pushes it
further saying oh there's different
kinds of nonsense right there's your
your trivial can of nonsense
and then there's real nonsense you know
and now what would be the difference
between them I have no clue you know
this is go ahead busy it feels almost
like something out of The Importance of
Being Earnest Victorian comedy of
manners like filed that away oh yeah
yeah I mean do you think the Red Queen
doesn't realize that she's talking crazy
at this point er well I don't know if
the Red Queen has any hesitating
consciousness at all it's hard to tell
well sure your life did well so if she
doesn't have this is kind of an
interesting thing to follow up if she
doesn't he have maybe she has an
interior life but she doesn't have a
concept of self or something like that
can she really be using language like
like we do maybe this is something where
comparison but yeah it makes me think a
little bit of the Marx Brothers where
eetu and Marx Brothers Groucho a hobo or
Chico Harpo Laurel boils for one another
yeah Groucho will come in in where the
straight man is well you know we use
like sort of formalized system of
language to turn it around on itself but
then Chico will come in and deliberately
seemingly misunderstand the misinterpret
what he's saying
using nonsense to then take over like
the thrust of the situation and
eventually Harpo will come in and just
cause chaos
and each one of them can kind of shut
the other one down
you know the Three Stooges do that too
right well they're talking back and
forth it's very fast repartee but
they're always whatever whatever way Moe
is talking about it curly or Shemp or
Mary Larry that's right Larry replaced
Shemp right I think they'll always take
it in a slightly different direction and
that's what that's what language allows
us to do it's a it's very malleable
there's those more meanings available at
any given time than nice logic can fit
it into but to go back to the Red Queen
thing so you know somebody who I was
teaching about earlier this week so my
students is Rene Descartes and in his
discourse on method he's interested in
talking machines because they had some
machines I could do you know they could
sort of like a very primitive robot they
could seemingly talk like us and he said
well how do I know that the people
around me are like that and he said well
one one sign of that is that machines
don't use language to communicate
thoughts at the end like in the inner
life right so is the Red Queen something
like that where she's just operating
according to a kind of programming and
she doesn't actually have any meetings
to what she's saying or I don't go that
far Thanks oh I think she's a neighbor
enabled and I think the Queen is a
representative of something in analysis
life and this is probably a person they
know who was always one up tonight oh
she's in the book I mean this is written
for Alice okay he wrote this for Alice
so you think that you know I think this
is a person they both interesting that's
my guess you're right and there are
people like that as Mary said there are
people we are
so now if you're new here it is this
parody of this person the idea of not
having an eternal life that would kind
of get back to your world building
question because if if Wonderland is
entirely incentive programs essentially
like that require you know a specific
input and then it's not a world right
well but it is more just like a
dreamscape fool then that would explain
why she's so disruptive when she comes
and she's giving the wrong input uh-huh
yeah sort of like she does what she
doesn't follow the rules of the game is
she's playing a different game and well
that screws things up like the nonsense
of the world is like a formalized
nonsense yeah the Queen's expecting
certain responses to what she says and
if she doesn't get them that's when
things go out of control
well I almost doesn't understand the
rules but I don't think they're really
already rules it's just whatever happens
we'll see pretty much akin to a chaotic
situation
alice is trying to Ellis thinks there
are our rules and he's trying to
understand them but I don't think there
are really already rules so then it
would just be sort of like made up as
they go along kind of add a certain
extent it is yeah I would say okay
there's another passage that I picked
out that is really famous the Humpty
Dumpty thing this ties in with with with
language as well so Humpty Dumpty says
there's glory for you and she says I
don't know what you mean by glory and
Humpty Dumpty smiles contemptuously of
course you don't
till I tell you I meant there's a nice
knockdown argument for you and Alice
very reasonably says but Gloria doesn't
mean a nice knock down an argument and
Humpty Dumpty says when I use a word in
a rather scornful tone it means just
what I choose it to me neither more nor
less and then Alice says the question is
whether you can make words mean so many
different things and then Humpty Dumpty
says the question is which is to be
master that's all whoever's in charge
gets to decide with the languages and
you better get with the program and he's
like that throughout it he's the one who
explains the Jabberwock
and if you think about the Jabberwocky
poem so now we're a bit of a digression
but it's one of the best parts of the
books right that's a it's a cool story
yeah I love the way that you know it's
showing you can tell a coherent story
that makes sense using like you're
saying nonsense words I mean whatever
whatever you decide
yeah well Humpty Dumpty he articulates a
reading of it where everything makes
sense right
he's got an explanation so slimy means
this and tolls means this and all of
that and now Carol wrote something about
this this is on the then the hunting of
the snark he says as this poem is to
some extent connected with the lay of
the Jabberwock let me take the
opportunity of answering a question
that's often been asked me how to
pronounce slithy Toves the I in slidy is
long as in ride that toes is pronounced
so as to write with groves again the
first I would borogroves is pronounced
like the OL and Baro
I've heard people try to give it the
sound of the oh and worry such as human
perversity he that he says yeah but he
says this also seems a fitting occasion
to notice the other hard words in that
poem Humpty Dumpty's theory of to
meetings packed into one word like a
portmanteau seems to me the right
explanation for all know I mean think
about that for a second Humpty Dumpty is
Carole's character right so now use
these saying yeah I think maybe that
character right but he himself composed
and so then he says take the words
fuming and furious make up your mind you
will say both words believe it unsettled
which you will sit with which you will
say first open your mouth and speak if
your thoughts incline ever so little
towards fuming you will say fuming
furious if they turn by even a hair's
breadth towards furious you'll say
furious from it fuming but if you have
the rarest of gifts a perfectly balanced
mind you will say frumious and that's
where he is saying all these words are
coming from Humpty Dumpty's getting it
right Humpty Dumpty's of jerk but he's
actually on track with
what the Jabberwocky means but here's
the other thing I'll say Matt the
Jabberwocky that goes you know whatever
you guys want to follow up with I'm
curious about what you make of the thing
when I get the X is when I have the
jammer walk by itself I think it's a
really cool poem I love the the nonsense
words in it and there's something I have
something kind of kind of mysterious
about it for me maybe it's because I
read it when I was young and had some
emotional attachments to it when the
poems explained I don't like it as much
you know now that I know that slithy is
supposed to be this now it's no longer
mysterious the the any do you have
similar experience when you're reading
the explanation there I think I think I
know what you're saying and I think it
comes down to that idea that you know
part of the idea of something like
poetry is to take words which are
familiar but to create a sensation which
is unique with them okay yeah yeah when
you realign like oh windy star blows
sideways up the sky if you analyze it it
means nothing any of that creates an
impression but if you get somebody to
break it down and say oh yeah I know
when he said Wendy he was thinking like
the wind you know the Moors Dartmoor
they might take away from your
experience here Shakespeare doesn't do
much they just translate everything into
literal
that was exciting yeah you know there's
there's there's translations in the
Jabberwock into French and German and
other languages and I haven't looked at
them for a long time but in Douglas
Hofstadter's gorilla shirt box that came
out he he likes Alice credit but he
talks about the different translations
and he was like Critias saying the
French one not so good
German want much better but it's all
nonsense where it's in those languages
that they're trying to use to to convey
other nonsense words how you determined
how close they are to the nonsense you
know I don't know that we have criteria
for that but what did the rest of you
make of the Jama right do you like do
you like it as a foamer do you I kind of
off-putting use your imagination with it
but I I wouldn't want it explained I
think everybody thinks it's like it's
like poetry it isn't supposed to it's
what you can't put into language so you
put it into poetry because just more of
an emotional feeling than it is than it
is an actual things so you know I can
understand what's going on there it does
it doesn't see that or paint to me yeah
I thought it was a better poem than the
hunting of the snark I have to say which
I reread for this me to again it goes on
too long parts of it are good but it's
just yeah generally it's really exciting
it's got action in it yes it's just the
right length yeah you know that's why
I've got a book here that I found in the
Marquette library it's called the
Philosopher's Alice and it's an
annotated version I'll pass this around
in just a minute the guy who wrote all
the annotations was a philosopher Peter
Heath and it was
done when in 1974 right so he's got all
these remarks about about stuff and he's
here's what he had to say about the the
Jabberwock he says the most curious
thing about this poem is that although
everyone agrees that it's great nonsense
nobody is prepared to leave it that way
Carroll himself
humpty-dumpty and a host of succeeding
commentators have labored diligently to
invent or discover meanings for
unfamiliar terms once this is done it
ceases to be nonsense and becomes a
miracle illogical puzzle apart from the
obscure first stanza there's in fact no
difficulty in following out the events
of the poem a sorry tale of the
destruction of innocent wild life
Alice's aesthetic reaction to it is
deplorable but at least she responds
appropriately to the combination of
clear structure with defective elements
of reference and descriptions of typical
wasp aright Hey she already says unlike
the critics she does not attempt to
supply the missing images but indulges
in a bout of imageless thought and then
he praises the German der junge walk he
says it's easily the best there there
actually there was another passage that
I had picked out that I wanted to to
bring oh yes it's the where the the the
queen is is giving her the heart annek
right so he he writes Alice sending a
contradiction calls it nonsense
presumably in an absolute sense the Red
Queen treats this as an adjustable and
relative term he or she has more of a
case because various kinds of nonsense
can be and have been distinguished some
of which might be considered more
nonsensical than others that's kind of
an interesting idea isn't it there's
like a hierarchy of nonsense and I says
much depends on the criteria for
nonsense employed and then he goes
through a bit of what what he thinks
about it and so I'll actually just pass
this around you can take a look at it
you know that's kind of an interesting
project to go through these these works
and then
you know say well here's I think with
what's going on I don't think it adds
too much to the work and but it is you
know it's funny that a philosopher would
attempt to do that isn't it
Mr Man didn't this note about somewhere
nonsensical than others I think it's
philosophy that has the principal not
even wrong once one makes a statement
that is so internally in coherence that
it can't even be proven correct or
incorrect oh because it there'd be no
conditions under which it could be said
to be wrong yeah ups the monitors yeah
you've got no no predicate you've got
nothing else you know I was talking to
so today I was actually teaching David
Hume to my students and we're going
through the inquiry regarding human
understanding and he was talking about
you know our Faculty of imagination and
he says you know you can easily imagine
a golden mountain and I do it right now
picture of mountain now I'll make it
gold you know and then he says and you
can also imagine to yourself a virtuous
horse but now it's starting to get a
little bit tougher what the hell does
that mean a virtuous horse well it
depends on what virtue so maybe we
attributed to the horse that that's
pretty easy but I don't know about you
know almost returning it to Khartoum
horses where we've already
anthropomorphised it you know the way we
do in Disney things last beauty it's
black beauty your purse yeah well right
yep so loyalty that with that we can do
can we talk about a horse being just or
chain-store I don't know that we can get
to all of that and then and then we can
go either further and we can talk about
things that we can't visualize like like
Heidegger's remark he was talking about
Christian philosophy he said Christian
philosophy is wooden higher what the
hell's wood nice all right if they use
try to say it's an absurdity you know
just by its definition you can't have
wood and iron and I told my students
okay picture is shelf wooden iron and
they just all looked at me like I was
nuts and then I said that's fine
all right picture a square circle and
then they were really convinced that I
was screwing with them what's that
picture of four-sided triangle yeah
there you go you know but there's some
things that they do key and I said well
what's going on there okay you're easy
you're very easily able to take golden
mountain and we'll just kind of squish
things together right and virtuous horse
it was a little bit tougher to get them
to fit but you could you know sort of
like Legos you click it the right way
and it works square circle no it's
almost like with magnets when you're
trying to push two magnets together and
they just push them off of each other
that was the only analogy I can think of
and I think some of the things in here
some of the nonsense maybe is like that
it's the level of absurdity questions
that can't be answered in the
affirmative the negative way you were
saying about how some precepts can be
proven yeah if I were to say show
someone a functioning iPhone they might
ask me a question like is this a word of
God or the devil yeah whoops the only
reasonable answer I can give is ask
about you know totally off topic but I
have two kids one of them is an 11 year
old boy and he likes to swear at Siri
and caller all sorts of names and stuff
like that and I tell them that's a
terrible terrible idea because what if
Siri right now Siri is a pretty pitiful
AI you know not really even an
artificial
intelligence this is just a mimicking
program that puts this well you so
here's the thing what now you know what
if we're able a to to attain AI within
our lifetimes and what if Siri gets
updated so that Siri really does become
self-aware and have an interior life and
memories and stuff like that then Siri
remembers this kid you know calling her
all sorts of names and you know telling
her to go screw herself and stuff like
that and then maybe Siri is vindictive
you're so nice area becomes insecure
well right well but then the thing that
I am I knew is the thing that I realized
his Siri actually thinks it's me talking
because it's all the index to Gregory so
even if it's my son and my daughter she
thinks I'm swearing so now my son has
put me on the hook if if Siri is
insecure and does acquire some
intelligence she's gonna take it ever
yeah I mean it's not really a connected
Alison let's hope you know this is a bit
off-topic are you guys familiar with
think whose bass oh no already made it
worse by talking about it you're right
so that's one maybe well should I show
you so that is it so it's called Roku's
bass on this moment and then the idea is
and then you guys can correct me if I
get it wrong if there's going to be in
the future some sort of you know they
talk about the singularity and all the
super III and stuff like that let's
let's assume there's gonna be a super
powerful AI some some time down in the
future well then either at this point in
time we're working to make that happen
or we're obstructing it in some way even
if we're not helping it then we're
because we're not we're not part of the
solution you're part of the problem now
imagine that that thing is so incredibly
intelligent that it figures out how to
go back in time if that's possible I
mean if anything could figure it I don't
be a super intelligent AI then it knows
whether we are at this point in time
contributing to its construction or
whether we're standing in the way and
it's also vindictive so if we if we're
not helping right now that it's going to
give us that's basically if the AI is
really smart though it would be afraid
of going back in time and tampering
because you're or know that's going to
happen it could it could unintentionally
prevent itself from being done what it's
trying to do is make itself get
developed quicker but it's super
intelligent right so we would have some
kind of a human yeah but you can't you
can only do so much with intelligence
when you're talking about random human
behavior yeah that's treatments are not
good why well and here's the thing so as
far as like the impact on us is once
we've actually talked about it it's sort
of like the ontological argument that
that and something's once you've
actually like open the box now they're
there they're most either there is such
a thing out there in the future or there
isn't if there isn't anything we're good
right
but if there is now we're all screwed
because we're not helping you're not and
you're better off not hearing about it's
the computer logic version of oh sure
now that the human being sort of talking
about it are just kind of
finally talking about it nobody's doing
anything about it our moderators freaked
out and that's why it became so popular
because one person seems to take it
seriously enough to ban all discussion
you know it's funny when I saw like when
I teach Rene Descartes and I teach the
meditations where he he says there could
be like this evil being he calls an evil
genius or demon it's a homage and in the
French and he says it devotes all of its
attention to fooling me it's super
powerful it's very clever and deceptive
and he doesn't actually believe that
lets his recitation like that every day
is a no-no his reputation is a bit more
complicated and it happens like in
meditation too that in meditation 3 and
so he's only bringing it up as a means
for him to down but there's always at
least like one or two students who read
that and they get freaked out they're
like wow this could be the case maybe
then there's different variations that
we have like you know they usually
almost always go to maybe this is like
the matrix maybe we're in a simulation
if you were going in a drill
yeah yeah and on because they all know
about Elon Musk and Elon Musk jested
that we're in a simulation so so that's
where some of them go and what's
interesting is that there's a effective
reaction of like anxiety well wait a
second what if this is actually true I
don't know that anybody I don't know
that it happens to anybody through you
know reading this I don't think that
maybe there are some people who get
anxious or upset reading
Wonderland they don't enjoy it the way
they're supposed to you know so much has
been this is such a perennial thing I
mean how much has come off of this it's
just Alison won't let you know it and it
just like builds on itself over and over
and over again and it is yeah I can
think I'm like four divisions I'm
connected to this thing like
phantasmagoria that's not else buddy I
worked in hitch up 16 years old my cat
was named Alison pleasant
let me Pleasants Alice Liddell I'm you
Pleasant Alice because the books didn't
know that her name was Alice pleasure
somebody need my campus my daughter
named her get Dino who was Ellis's you
know tutor anything all of these things
that came on a book story that we just
read you know well you know that was one
there was one reason why I wanted to
cover you know for this series this year
I wanted the first for to be people who
are influential on the authors that
we've been reading it and I think you're
right Alice Alice in Wonderland on the
whole like nonsense stuff it influence
Douglas Adams who we did a while back
it's influenced a lot of people who are
like this nonsense stuff is kind of fun
to play around with you know we can we
didn't go further than what was it so
attractive in the 60s I mean you were
air shows and then was some pills make
you larger why would I want stepmother
don't you go to it just was I just think
it was huge
sometimes the honey would become so long
you know what this dr. Kuzma song came
out with the song popular' just came out
of this story this era was huge everyone
was reading it everyone I mean it was
just it was I don't know also was the
advent of LSD and so it was
tell them to find a songwriter who
wanted to pull the laboratory degree of
the space tuition did come out of it but
I mean that wasn't good for that wasn't
pretty precipitate event that was an
outcome it was such a huge precipitation
of yeah listen wonder maybe it was
because it was the psychedelic time and
this was so weird and I think you could
see a lot of well you know we learn you
into fantasy we're giving you an amount
in country what was in it I mean if the
music the Jeff Slater shows well yeah I
mean that that song came from the
psychedelic movement but it probably
because of the of the nonsense of it it
just fit right in is it because you
could read whatever you wanted into it
or maybe I think it was more than the
people who are coming to adulthood or
near adulthood in the 60s were raised
you know under the idea and I guess
we're still kind of hard to the extent
that however your society functions is
the absolute capital-t truth or the
right way to do things in it there's
really only one way in which to go about
living or existing or thinking or doing
doing things yeah yeah you're either
doing it right or doing it wrong and
reading through something like that
suggests that those things are actually
a diversion
yeah you couldn't resist which yes yeah
I mean it just it was just sold you know
early enormous and then when children
everyone they just a lot of grading
where to 90 would buy my influence and
it just lobbed into it now thinking yeah
well I'm willing to bet there's gonna be
generations of kids long after we're all
gone who really enjoyed reading this too
but maybe they're maybe they'll make
very different things out of it
the current Star Trek Star Trek
discovery oh how so it follows Spock's
adopted sister and a Spock's human
mother Amanda reads Alice in Wonderland
to both swaggins of God and sister
Michael and she explains that it's
parsley to give them an understanding of
nonsense because Vulcan culture yeah
yeah that you provided and because it's
a Star Trek show they're running into a
lot of really strange stuff in space and
they're finding it's sort of therapeutic
to remember Alice in Wonderland and how
she navigates the world that makes no
sense
because now they're in a world that
makes no sense so it provides a kind of
pattern or solidarity here I don't know
what you could learn from behavior from
how Alice is coping with this well
somehow would that inform your except to
make you feel better about being in a
nonsense but you know she's not afraid
very much and one day that's actually
one of the other things well one of the
effects one of the themes that I wanted
to bring up was how much there's
references to anger in this it's it's
the one effect that gets brought up the
most there there's some there are some
fear like the rabbits you know in a
hurry and he's anxious about things but
there's characters who get angry and a
lot of times they're getting getting
angry at how other people are using
language or the nonsense that's there
and one of the remark or one of the
passages like I picked is it's a second
one right the first page
Alice finally had enough and this is
where the the adventure ends there's
dead silence on the court while the
white rabbit write out the verses the
that's the most important piece of
evidence we've heard yet so the king I
don't believe there's an atom of meaning
in adventure analysis if there's no
meaning in its of the king let's say
it's a world of trouble you knows we
needn't try to find any let the jury
consider their verdict no no so the
Queen sentence first verdict afterwards
stuff and nonsense said Alice loudly the
idea of having the sentence for she
wants things to be in order hold your
tongues of the Queen turning purple I
won't sit Alice
off with her head the Queen shouted at
the top
boys nobody moved who cares for you
she'd grown a full size by now you're
nothing but a pack of cards at this the
whole pack rose up in the air came
flying down upon her she gave a little
scream half of fright and a half of
anger tried to beat them off and found
herself laying on the bank Alice's had
enough of this nonsense
and she has a sort of affective reaction
towards it and there's you know there's
other characters in there who are angry
all the time that the red you know the
Red Queen's often everybody's had seems
like a angry response doesn't go
anywhere Tweedledee and tweedle
Tweedledum are angry at each other and
and there's there's a couple other
places where somebody says something and
then the other person is like you know
their response is is anger and I started
thinking about this and as well we do an
angry when we think somebody's either
like twisting our words or when we
encounter actual nonsense
one response to nonsense is confusion
but another response is I hate this
right or I want this to go away or I'm
ticked off and your time ever being
pressed ruined right but I was thinking
about that maybe this is I don't know
you know I don't know enough about
Carol's psychology to go very far with
this but what happened to the real Alice
Liddell as she aged did she ever come
back and write anything about her
childhood experiences with this day I
don't know it's a good question really
eight years ago they had some she was
she was invited so I think like a Peter
Pan you know why no I mean you know they
had they had this is probably the 70s or
something yeah nobody saw I can't
was about Allison the woman like she
would be dreaming as an as an adult that
she would dream like going back to some
of this stuff I know that at an
anniversary of the publication of Alice
in Wonderland she was invited to New
York to give a talk of some sort
but I don't I don't know I was reading
on a background stuff and I don't
remember what the talk was titled or
about and she must have been like you
know in a way it would be kind of
frustrating right to be always labeled
as the Alice of Alice in Wonderland you
know I mean if you some people would
probably make a lot of hay out of it you
know go around you have publicity to a
hearse something like that but I don't I
I get the idea that she was we don't
know maybe she was punished one woman
anyway but was touched in some way she
felt that and yeah there was something
there was something like where where she
was in conflict with family members you
know as a child in there I wish I could
remember the whole was it fictional
lower um or was it supposed to be a
documentary it wasn't a documentary it
was it was a movie but maybe it was just
based on supposition - but it was kind
of I just remembered that and it was as
her because it I remember standing in
front of this mirror is an adult and
just kind of recalling what was written
about and and like somebody had been
telling you wrote the story told the
tale yeah she was she was just it was
you know we act about her reaction it
was too long ago too many movies since I
can't
yeah relative to anger as your time yeah
else do you feel like throughout the
course of the book house goes from like
the two different responses like you're
saying a nonsense from going I don't get
this what's wrong with me - I don't get
this what's wrong with you yeah I think
that I think that is the case and I
think I think that's actually reasonable
response well as you're getting more and
more opinionated over these people are
screwed up you don't think yeah you face
something you don't understand for the
first or second time you might think
well this could be over yeah remember
again she eventually realizes no it's
not yeah I do feel like there's a you
know there's there's a few other things
too where there's a similar dynamic like
it that the Tea Party all right
everybody at the Tea Party's nuts she's
like I'm not that's well obviously you
are because you're here she doesn't she
doesn't accept that you know she's
challenging the status quo he says no
you you're just like we are
that's right yeah it does seem like she
eventually starts fighting is that no
well you know there's there's one other
thing too that I I am put it into the
theme as such and I meant to talk about
it in the world-building part that we we
got away from very quickly and it was so
in the beginning of Looking Glass it's
clear that Alice is very imaginative and
she's the one who can already sort of
like get into this this thing and she
tries to structure a cat but she also
tries to get her her sister here we go
she had had quite long an argument with
her sister only the day before all
because Alice had begun with let's
pretend we're kings and queens and her
sister who like being very exact and
argued they couldn't because there are
only two of them and Alice had been
reduced at last
well you can be one of them and I'll be
all the rest which is not a bad idea you
know and then this she says once she
really frightened her old nurse by
shouting suddenly in her ear nurse let's
do pretend that I'm a hungry hyena and
Europe bone so Alice clearly is able to
she's got some flexibility you know some
imaginative capacities right and the
other people around her are either
scared by it or annoyed by it but then
she gets in with these people and
there's sort of an opposite extreme with
people inside the looking glass
so many of them are very inflexible all
right they've got their stick and they
stick to it so yeah I have a question
for you okay so you you said earlier
like that
you believe in hundred years you've also
been reading and analyzing Alice's well
I said children so be it but but I'm
sure they'll be guilty some editor II
people analyzing and I think you're
right
why do you think that particular story
as opposed to some of the other
fantasies that came between like this
and what brings count remember the way
did as opposed to say like hope
America's love in the mist or water or
something like that
yeah where or yeah where where people
don't dig these things up unless they're
kind of digging around and do you know
do you think there's something specific
about this which well Byrne did
something to everybody or was it sort of
a right time I think part of it is once
this isn't a complete explanation but
once you attain a certain level of
popularity there's some you know there
was nothing succeeds like success
once you've like gotten onto the
people's radar they keep publishing your
books it's probably also helped by the
fact that the Dodgson estate you know it
was seemed to be fairly well organized
and keeping his memory alive whereas a
lot of the people that we have looked at
in the series you know they would write
and things like the pulps another work
are just going to disappear unless
somebody revived even even somebody who
are going to look at next
in August August Derleth if he and
republished if he hadn't started Arkham
House and we published Lovecraft's pulp
stuff probably Lovecraft would be a much
more obscure kind of like a tentatively
named Clarence Memphis yeah exactly yeah
yeah that's that's all I really got
I mean part of it could be right place
right time like he mentioned other
people started writing similar books
after him I would guess it's in part
because they saw the commercial success
and he seemed to think that it was the
genre was tapped out because of that you
know it'd almost be like if because you
know another perfectly reasonable
reaction of that it occurs to me would
be to say oh you know people have been
playing with this but I'm better at them
I'm better at that than they are or you
could say oh oh this is really cool
we've got this little burgeoning
universe of interesting stories I'm
going to keep adding to it right and so
he's like that you guys are doing it I'm
not going to do it anymore
you know we were talking about what was
his name the Cornelius Chronicles
Michael Moorcock before right Michael
Moorcock offer the Cornelius Chronicles
one one of the good things about it is
that he offered it as sort of a template
that anybody could hand whatever they
wanted to write and people did I don't
know if I haven't read any I don't know
if any of them already good
why couldn't you know Lewis Carroll
adopt a similar sort of view of you know
that's similar to what you'd seen as
something I've seen DC Comics the
character of that yeah you have a
character who obviously over time
ultimately to come in write and rewrite
there you know elements of their past
even though that you know some of the
basics of only staying the same so you
get different back then the Batman of
the 60s was on the movie police
department very very can't they have any
good that I can use was very serious and
yeah you could have done something
similar with
I suppose yeah I'm not really you know
this is totally aggression I'm not sure
what to make of all the different
Batman's
and now all the different jokers I have
a hard time kinda like figuring out what
I'm supposed to do with with them is
media things at my head and I haven't
even seen all the Batman you know I like
Batman as a kid and I kinda like when
he's darker than when he's campy there's
definitely some of the actors who I'm
not interested in seeing play Batman
there's there somewhere I've got
interested in seeing play The Joker but
so many different depictions of them III
don't quite it seems like there's too
many for me know now there's campy and
then the music they played this song and
he's got these moves he does to sing
with his shoulders he gets down there it
is kind of stocky babies like it's like
a linebacker two-year-old and he's
moving like oh my gosh
but is he playing bat me owner no then
there's these these songs in Batman Lego
Batman there's these I musical so
somebody knows it sounds very well done
okay but it's so campy you got these
Lego give the labels there and and he's
got this like girlfriend and then
there's oh Jesus it's so cold
well I think of a show right there
[Music]
okay well that that's that that's that's
one who doesn't is dance like parental
bonuses as references to ruling stuff
yes very complicated
Alfred's like Bruce what has gotten into
you and the [ __ ] in the whole flashback
of all the different bed every sway to
somehow penalize the sixties for this
not age they don't explain it mommy
gonna have a real real deep love for
like the history of the character to the
extent of it like voice actors doing
minor rule will be voice actors who
reference in some way as a Batman in the
hour the actor played Lando Calrissian
was named like oh yeah
does the voice on the character to the
face in that film now if any of you
remember the 1989 Batman Billy Dee
Williams play or did he you know I've
seen all the Batman of all and it gives
them some of its hearty done it becomes
the yeah two days so it's this little
friendly records bag for all the parents
for watching you know it's an
interesting time that we live in because
both like the DC and the Marvel leaders
all these movies all these TV shows and
things like that whereas you know we
were younger I mean you have a show once
in a while like there's a terrible
spider-man show you know cartoon for
yeah but there wasn't much if it was a
you have the comic books I know why she
did that
who else partner with the Lord of the
Rings is is that the version where it
was just like only the first half of
yeah got made yeah although I remember
with that was there was ice on that and
there was they have song where the works
were like whipping people away right
you know I there I only know the Disney
Alice in Wonderland but I think there
there's there's quite a few other
another live-action they've had so many
I mean there's like at least two or
three animated ones to the analog other
elements in or is there enough stuff
just in this story without to do the
entire well not anymore
that last Alice in Wonderland they had
to save the world
oh really well one vision capitalized I
mean is to serialize these things true
yeah you know yeah take you gotta pull
apart you can't do them all on a tour
movie you won't make enough partner so
yeah you know again has been off topic
but it I always found it a little bit
funny of that so the Lord of the Rings
you know this big thick three-volume set
that can be just three movies because
missile Lord of the Rings films could
have been expanded further that was
earlier they didn't realize they could
do it and get away with it
45 minutes
now although we can get three movies out
Harry Potter series started I think
breaking the deathly hallows up to - yes
okay my way to them seems like the books
keep getting longer and longer
yeah oh wow because they didn't think
they'd get to funding for 13 they really
missed it is 2 and then we're in the
studio max you say well this is maybe
only to get a funny even for three
movies so I think that's a big part of
why I can't cry it down yeah and now now
we're at a time where you know the
streaming services are producing tons
and tons of their own content and then
presumably you know well you know
Tolkien is going to be I forget if it's
on Amazon or is it a blender is it a
Netflix
they're doing the Summerlin really best
like two hundred million dollars you
don't think that original comedy doesn't
have the right so no no because it's not
their original content
yeah the Tolkien estate can grant it to
as many people as they want to doesn't
Peter talking disapprove instead of a
sign sign of Tolkien was the one who
sold the rights for the original Lord of
the Rings - oh here talking the guy who
co-authored the summer lien
didn't want him to
that might be probably interesting right
now
yeah there's quite a lot of content from
the authors that we've been looking at
it you know that is number 35 so we've
done a lot of other authors quite a few
of them are getting brought into the
series or movies or things sometimes not
quite so successful we talked about a
wrinkle in time that one got pretty
pretty bad leap and you know is very
pretty well you know once we could think
that they diverged so much from by
really sort of moral of all the
universal you know in a way we could
think about that as like a failure of
world building well then we test a
reckon in all of the Medicare I mean all
of it and it was important Stephanie to
sort of she's over that yeah well I mean
you know I think they probably do that
because I think people can't follow the
story or they're not going to be as
interested in it you know I you know I
said we got these little bitty grandsons
and they can figure stuff out like you
were doesn't leave well so I'm usually
kind adult we be able to look at
children's books no oh no there's no
there because they're being into
superheroes and I'm always getting
chastised by their mother yeah but you
know the Star Wars gonna Sarah was
targeted injures ten-year-old boys I
mean then it just took off more yeah and
it's still targeted for tenure well over
the or the or the you know thirty
year-old equivalent right
it's it's it's it's not like anything
you're ever going to see anywhere really
when they complete it isn't there's
there's nothing near to her linear about
it it's just an experience from let me
also check about ant you have to see
it's probably gonna start if done again
will be season four but I mean it you'd
have to start with season water and make
no pretense whatsoever yeah but it's
it's just yes let me ask you a question
that bazaars can be let me ask a
question that we would never have asked
like fifteen years ago
is that the sort of thing that would be
would benefit from binge watching it or
would that be like too much to watch and
do you need like time to kind of like
mull over both yeah both he said there's
nothing it's just you people that
baskets over there gets walking around
with but there is there is kind of a
plotline it's almost it's supposed to be
like based on these these people with
these superpowers but yet they're in
this mental institution but yet the
existent they don't exist
oh and Dan Stevens is the main guy you
know and then it and then there's this
there's this guy if there's a guy in a
you know in a one of those under kind
suits on who's up in this room I mean
there's nothing that makes any sense at
all but once you start watching you know
kinda like oh wow I gotta keep seeing
this even though it's almost like a Mike
Miller you can well that's a good sort
of way to bring this this all back full
circle doesn't make sense maybe that's a
good recommendation here's a little bit
of a plot you know what the first season
could maybe be something like that but
they would
or into this this king they're trying to
find these in these different bodies and
their dragon that the guy in this pile
it was a senior crowd yeah what's up
guys you asked me because you watch me
seems like you're familiar with a lot of
this maybe there's our stuff but that's
probably like free range yeah maybe then
maybe they allowed the writers to have
like total free reign or something and
it's it's different yeah okay well is
there anything else that you guys want
to say about Alice or Lewis Carroll or I
was really really curious about this and
you say bread did you read that
oh yeah I work I when I was an
undergraduate I worked through it okay
and one might actually encounter Charles
Dodgson and they play a game with him
called sorties and all of the moves in
the game like all the things that they
do in the game ours are spelled out but
they never explained the rules that I
never quite felt like I understood it
it's a minimal logical game yeah do you
know well I mean he's so he's got the
symbolic logic and then he's got the
game of logic and it's been a long time
since I've actually like looked through
all this Essaouira days is a an argument
that's got that's like a long chain
right you may have all these different
statements and you're supposed to figure
out look this statement being made but
that seemed to be what was going on but
how exactly they will
let me see let me take a very quick look
I don't know if he covers that this this
part the game of logic in a way it's a
misnomer right so he's got these
diagrams it's basically how you can do
how you can do logical arguments you can
represent them and analyze them with
these squares or you place counters and
stuff like that so then it's not a game
as such but then you know where it gets
fun is where he has like these these
long they're not arguments is such that
they're more like he gives you a bunch
of statements you know like when you do
those logic puzzles where it says well
Brown is sitting next to green and green
he has a purple hat on and you have to
figure out what the conclusion is right
who's got the thimble or what whatever
it happens to be he will give you
sometimes up to like 20 different
statements like that and then as opposed
to like what we had because we'd get
those in math class you know like extra
credit thing or I would say well who's
got the thimble he just says what's the
conclusion to draw you know and I don't
know if that's related to know we've
used it the game was definitely they
were making statements and you're
sounding statements yeah that's kind of
cool all all the claims I make it not
spiders are false or oh then we're
getting to like self-referential claims
right and that that makes it more
complicated as soon as you start
referencing your own language you
introduce a new wrinkle into things and
then I was doing a lot of that you know
when I was an undergraduate I was a
philosophy of mathematics major and so
for my senior thesis I started examining
batches of what we call truth self
referential statements where you were
the most common and the most basic one
is what I'm telling you is false
no the liars paradox right or I am a
liar if I if I'm lying well that it's
true but if it's true that it's false
right there's a paradox there and I
managed to show using mathematical
functional modeling that all truth self
referential statement groups could be
boiled down to either the liars paradox
or just a tautology and then you know
I'll tell you another funny story so
when I applied for graduate school I had
no idea what I was doing excited first
generation college and I knew I had to
do a writing sample and I realized that
the the senior thesis that I've done
about truth self referential statement
groups which is requiring this
mathematics and stuff like that that you
could actually model it with the Lybia
strip so there's a geometrical analog to
that so I wrote a little like five page
piece about them and I sent it in as my
writing sample now most people are like
sending in things like those do you know
Dee Kurtz you know really in a dream or
not or human induction or stuff like
that and I talked with the chair and he
said man it's a good thing you had high
test scores because we couldn't figure
out what the hell that is admitted was
and I you know I thought it was
perfectly reasonable but they are all
like what the hell is this crap you know
you know yeah I just pictured it myself
the the committee the admissions
committee looking at this and some guy
is talking about well it might you know
my senior thesis that demonstrated that
this may be like okay I don't get that
so far now I'm going to come up with a
geometrical modeling for it why the hell
would you just yeah well I'll ask you in
that they essentially look at this look
at your test score Suleman well I assume
thank you - literally they just couldn't
follow your ear yeah you're just I don't
know that they thought that it made
sense I think they were like well he's
got many test scores I won't give up
we'll give him a chance he's not a
relative what whether or not you were
making since you were capable of it
exactly yeah yeah I was I was very
fortunate you know there's a lot of like
needles that I've managed to like
somehow get through the threat where I
could have easily barked off and god
that's perfect you know right place
right time yeah
and it's unfortunate because that's not
the case for most people were trying to
get into graduate studies the days not
much much harder for them
[Music]
you